nato general egon ramms er ist uns
zugeschaltet ich grüße sie herr am
guten teuer werden herms sie haben die
regierungserklärung des bundeskanzlers
verfolgt da ging es ja unter anderem
auch um die militärischen aspekte der
hilfe die deutschland leistet hat sie da
irgend etwas überrascht erfreut da oder
wie würden sie momentan die
hilfeleistungen aus deutschland bewerten
wir können uns gleich nochmal gemeinsam
die veröffentlichte liste anschauen
also mich hat eigentlich bei der
regierungserklärung des bundeskanzlers
nicht allzuviel überrascht denn es ist
im prinzip eine zusammenfassung der
ereignisse gewesen die seitdem dort der
rede zur zeitenwende am 27 stattgefunden
haben natürlich auch mit veränderungen
dabei wir wissen alle wie lange die
bundesregierung gebraucht hat um zu
entscheiden schwere waffen in die
ukraine zu liefern gestern sind die
panzerhaubitzen angekommen das ist eine
verstärkung für die ukrainische
artillerie die die ukrainische
artillerie dazu befähigen wird die
russische artillerie zu bekämpfen und
die hhla die überlegenheit der russen
des ausgesprochen groß
das ist wichtig für die ukraine genauso
wie das thema schwere waffen wie immer
sagen ich würde lieber von panzern und
schützenpanzern
mannschaftstransportwagen gepanzerten
transportwagen reden und das etwas
besser zu spezifizieren und vielleicht
auch das durcheinander ein bisschen zu
werden die ukraine braucht diese systeme
einfach um gegen die russen weiterhin
entsprechend kämpfen zu können und sie
braucht sie vor allen dingen wenn sie
die absicht hat geländegewinne zu
erzielen und damit die russen in
wichtigen bereichen
zurück zu drücken ich bin davon
überzeugt wenn solche waffen in größerer
zahl bereits da gewesen wären sähe die
lage investitionen und es fehlt uns
vielleicht etwas anders aus als sie
heute aussieht sehen sie vielleicht
schon anders aber wir können wie gesagt
gerne noch mal gemeinsam schauen auf
unserer seite zdf heute.de haben wir
nochmal zusammengefasst welche waffen
deutschland bereits geliefert bzw welche
noch geliefert werden sollen da ist eben
auch von den schweren waffen systemen
die sie gerade angesprochen haben die
rede also 30 flac panzer des typs g7
panzerhaubitzen die sind inzwischen
angekommen drei mehrfach raketenwerfer
maß mit munition etc das alles ist wie
gesagt auf dieser seite nachzulesen das
ist teilweise schon da teilweise aber
noch in planung auch weitere 54
gepanzerte truppentransporter auch die
hatten sie gerade schon angesprochen
das soll noch kommen und dann ist aber
auch auf diese auflistung dabei das
bereits 25 punkte
1 838 punkte manchmal ein bisschen
schwierig hier den überblick zu behalten
38 punkte wurden aufgeführt die bereits
geliefert sind 16 millionen schusswaffen
munition das sind ja auch unvorstellbare
mengen die jedenfalls mir als laien groß
vorkommen wie würden sie wenn sie jetzt
noch einmal darauf schauen und sich eben
auch noch mal vor augen führen was
bereits geliefert wurde und was noch
aussteht das bewerten und wie schnell
vor allem muss jetzt das gerät kommen
lassen sich mit der letzten frage
anfangen also ist besteht in der ukraine
mit blick auf den kampf gegen die
russischen kräfte ein ungeheurer
zeitdruck und jeder quadratmeter boden
der unter ukraine verloren geht muss
nach den sag mal leitlinien des
präsidenten irgendwann wieder zurück
erobert werden und zurück erobern ist
möglicherweise schwieriger als
erfolgreich verteidigen das heißt wir
haben einen die menschen zeitpunkt
dahinter und alle länder die die ukraine
unterstützen auch die bundesrichter
stand sollten sich darum bemühen dieses
material so schnell wie möglich an die
ukraine zu liefern um die ukrainische
streitkräfte für einen erfolgreichen
kampf zu befähigen und diesen
erfolgreichen kampf brauchen wir denn
nach meiner auffassung ist wladimir
putin und russland zur zeit dabei ich
formuliere das mit meinen worten ein
volk zu vernichten dafür sprechen auch
die deputation die air durchgeführt hat
die trennung von familien und kindern
adoptionen von kindern deren eltern
möglicherweise noch leben und
dergleichen dinge mehr das heißt er will
die ukraine als einen teil russlands
komplett besetzen und er möchte im
prinzip das ukrainische volk auf diese
art und weise vernichten und das ist
eine sache die wir auch gerade wir
deutsche mit unserer geschichte in
keinem fall zu lassen sollten von daher
besteht hoher zeitdruck und sie sollten
alles tun die waffen so schnell wie
möglich dorthin zu bekommen
katerina art der andere teil der andere
teil der frage
der andere teil der frage ich möchte
jetzt nicht auf diese 38 positionen der
gelieferten artikel eingehen weil es
dann vom verbandpäckchen bis zur
verpflegung hätte spannender gesagt
ziemlich verzetteln würden so richtig
ist dass diese sachen geliefert worden
sind dass die ukraine sie braucht dass
die ukraine sie hat und lieferungen
dieser art so sehe ich das im augenblick
werden auch weitergehen weil die ukraine
einen bestimmten rückhalt brauchen ein
bestimmtes backup braucht um die
gefechte weiter führen zu können und die
ukraine ist praktisch selbst nicht mehr
in der lage krieg später in dieser art
zu produzieren
von daher ist sich zu 100 prozent auf
die hilfe von außerhalb angewiesen und
da sollte deutschland sich in jedem fall
bemühen auch eine wichtige rolle zu
spielen
katharina art fragt uns über youtube wie
lang kann dieser krieg noch dauern das
ist natürlich eine frage die schwer zu
beantworten sein dürfte aber wie würden
sie es jetzt anhand der momentanen
entwicklung vielleicht einschätzen
also ich gehe davon aus dass wir am ende
des krieges in diesem jahr nicht mehr
erleben werden das ist meine
hochrechnungen die kann sogar falschen
möglicherweise geht es auch länger auch
das hängt davon ab wann die ukraine mehr
waffen bekommt und die waffen kriegt um
die russischen streitkräfte entsprechend
bekämpfen zu können und solange das
nicht möglich ist oder sagen der zustand
der ukrainischen streitkräfte so ist wir
zurzeit ist und wo vor allen dingen die
große kampfes leistung der ukrainischen
streitkräfte von der kampfmoral abhängig
ist wird es keine wende geben höchstens
band lokalen gefechten in saison zum
beispiel wo die ukrainische soldaten
dann vielleicht ein paar
quadratkilometer boden zurückgewinnen
werden die übrigens taktisch nicht
unwichtig sind weil das wichtig wäre die
russen hinter diesem fluss zurück zu
werfen also mindestens ein halbes jahr
oder länger und es hängt ab von der
unterstützung die wir liefern lassen sie
mich die gelegenheit nutzen auf die eine
bemerkung einzugehen jährige lieferte
waffe verlängert den krieg die sie
vorhin zitiert haben ja ich finde diese
bemerkung finde ich menschenunwürdig und
zwar aus folgendem grunde jemand der das
schreibt und damit im prinzip putin
seinen siegen gibt die ukraine zu
erobern ist
mit beteiligt an der verpflichtung des
ukrainischen volkes und das ist eine
schreckliche idee für mich
ich würde gerne mit ihnen noch einmal
auf einen spezifischen punkt sozusagen
in der ukraine zu sprechen kommt jeder
donetzk schwer auszusprechen seit wochen
ist der ort in den schlagzeilen weil es
sich dort eben eine tapfer muss man
sagen kämpfen der ukrainische minderheit
noch hält befürchtet wird aber eben seit
wochen die ein casino einkesselung
dieser truppen durch russland wir haben
da auch eine karte verbreitet vielleicht
gucken wir da gerade noch mal drauf und
dann können wir das vielleicht auch an
der stelle noch mal etwas genauer zeigen
so wurde es mir jedenfalls gesagt wenn
wir die karte nicht haben ist es nicht
weiter tragisch dann frage ich sie so
wie würden sie die situation was diesen
ort angeht beschreiben
wir haben uns in dieser sendung würde
ich das richtig erinnere vor etwa 14
tagen über dieses thema schon mal
unterhalten und ich habe damals die
empfehlung gegeben dass es vielleicht
deshalb wäre mit einer front begradigung
von der ukrainischen seite her die
truppen aus diesem teil herauszunehmen
und auf diese art und weise
menschenleben zu sparen die man
möglicherweise hinter für den weiteren
krieg noch brauchen wird und auf diese
art und weise b auch die gefahr einer
einkesselung und diese dinge einfach
zu minimieren darf der kurdischen frage
nach hatte gerade das weiß jetzt nicht
jeder was ist damit gemeint
ok also es geht darum dass in diesem ich
nenne das mal ein sack der sich dort
gebildet hat mit den russischen
streitkräften
die gefahr besteht dass diese beiden
städte lustig ganz grundsätzlich
eingeschlossen werden und damit dann
ukrainische soldaten zu kriegsgefangenen
werden oder von den russen gar getötet
werden und das könnte man möglicherweise
mit einem oder hätte man vorher mit
einem taktischen rückzug vermeiden
können ob dieser taktischen rückzug noch
funktioniert dafür fehlen mir im
augenblick die details verstehen wie
schätzen sie denn insgesamt die
situation ein gerade wenn wir jetzt mal
auch über das material sprechen sie
hatten gerade schon auch die moral
angesprochen unsere kollegen vor ort
katrin einkauf konnte uns jedenfalls
keine gegenteiligen eindrücke schildern
also die sei offenbar noch intakt aber
wenn wir jetzt mal auf das material
schauen da werden zahlen gemeldet von
zehn sache überlegenheit teilweise 15 20
facher überlegenheit wie viele reserven
hat russland noch was was glauben sie
also ich denke dass die reserven
russlands mittlerweile auch angegriffen
worden sind und von daher sich auch
einschränken dazu kommt eine
interessante aussage die gestern gemacht
worden ist in den russischen kanälen
nämlich die aussage dass man kräfte
bereithalten wird im bereich der drei
baltischen staaten damit man dort nicht
in ein risiko rein läuft das was dort
völlig überflüssiger weise
möglicherweise an kräften von von diesen
drei baltischen staaten russischen
kräften gebunden wird führt dazu dass
diese kräfte auf dem gefechtsfeld in der
ukraine nicht auftauchen können von
daher dass in interessanten nebeneffekt
obwohl diese blockade insbesondere von
metallwaren und dergleichen mehr
eigentlich keine kriegshandlung ist soll
wie wichtig die ausführung der
sanktionen durch die europäische union
beschlossen worden sind apropos
sanktionen ich es vielleicht noch mal
die ein oder andere user meinung vor ich
glaube nicht schreibt uns nm über
youtube dass russland wegen der
sanktionen aufhören wird auch wenn die
sanktionen ab herbst stärker wirken
hauptziel von putin ist es die
sowjetunion wieder herzustellen gelände
boards meint aber ob eine ausweitung des
konflikts noch zu finden ist möchte ich
doch mehr als bezweifeln also offenbar
auch auf andere staaten es sollte keine
diplomatische lösung geben auch wenn man
das kaum begreifen kann vielleicht mal
die sie auch eine diplomatische lösung
so sehe ich das
kommen wir noch mal auf die aktuelle
klasse
kommentieren ja klar
also ich möchte noch mal den hinweis
geben wirklich den nachdrücklichen
hinweis geben dass es nicht um die frage
geht wo wir den russen entgegenkommen
können oder dergleichen sondern nicht
verweise auf das was friedrich merz als
oppositionsführer gesagt hat dort wo wir
westlichen staaten dazu zählen alle also
auch die bundes rück deutschland signale
senden dass wir uns mit den russen an
einen verhandlungstisch setzen wollen
zeigen wir aus putins perspektive
schwäche und er wird bereit sein diese
schwäche in jeder form ausnutzen das
heißt die geschlossenheit von unserer
seite
und das fortsetzen der unterstützung in
der ukraine ist letztlich ein starkes
signal auch an leute mit putin und ich
möchte ihren zuschauer vielleicht ein
bisschen die sorge nehmen ich gehe nicht
davon aus dass putin jetzt will litauen
oder an anderer stelle einen krieg gegen
die nato vom zaun brechen wird denn ich
bin mir ziemlich sicher dass er weiß
dass er diesen krieg nicht gewinnen kann
von daher wäre das dann auch ein
erheblicher nachteil für russland selber
den er so vermute ich dass trotz
manchmal fehlen rationales nicht bereit
das hinzunehmen
hier haben wir noch eine zuschrift die
militärisches wissen offenbar
voraussetzt sanktionen richten in
deutschland deutlich mehr schaden an und
russland hat den längeren atem außerdem
außerdem geht von kaliningrad eine reale
gefahr aus klammer auf iskander raketen
mit atomsprengköpfen
was würden sie diese zuschrift entgegnen
also kaliningrad kaliningrad hat immer
schon truppen stationiert gehabt hat
immer schon teile der baltischen flotte
der russlands und vorher auch der
sowjetunion gehabt in kaliningrad war
immer ein ich sag das mal militär
verschiebe platz für die russische oder
die sowjetische seite wir leben mit
diesem zustand im prinzip seit 1946 also
auch nachdem die nato 49 gegründet wurde
ist haben wir diesen zustand
weitergetragen und ich bin so ehrlich zu
sagen dass ich mir ein paar mal die
frage gestellt habe warum lassen hier
eine situation wie diese zu ohne
überhaupt über kaliningrad und diese
situation nachzudenken wenn putin davon
ausgehen kann dass alles was er
russisches als russisches territorium
bezeichnet ein sanktuarium ist muss er
sich über russland keine sorgen machen
das hat diesen krieg egal wie der
ausgeht in jedem fall entsprechend
überleben
ich sehe die gefahr eines angriffs auf
die nato sehe ich nicht weil die nato
weiterhin und das wird sie in der
nächsten woche auch beim gipfel tun sehr
deutlich machen wird dass die nato ihr
territorium verteidigt keinen
angriffskrieg gegen russland
beabsichtigt von daher gibt es keinen
grund es sei denn putin will den auf
teufel komm raus dabei reden um seine
eigene handlung zu rechtfertigen und das
macht er und das machen seine männer
beispielsweise auch die regelmäßig mit
den militärischen erfolgen im fernsehen
auftreten ausgesprochen geschickt
wir müssen lernen dass russland eine
harte verhandlungstaktik betreibt und
wir müssen eine silbe harten
verhandlungstaktik seinem verhalten
hingegen sitzen sonst kommen wir nie an
einen echten verhandlungstisch wo dann
tatsächlich über die zukunft der ukraine
nach den vorgaben der ukraine verhandelt
werden kann aber die äußerungen was die
nato auch die bereitschaft angeht der
nato-staaten jeden zentimeter sozusagen
des territoriums zu verteidigen die
halten sie für glaubhaft weil hier
schreibt uns papa klaus über youtube
körper klaus klepper strauß heißt sowohl
die nato oder er ist ein alibi bündnis
bei einem angriff russlands wird niemand
litauen helfen außer mit
waffenlieferungen wie sehen sie das
also ich das sehe ich anders die
bekenntnisse aller nato staaten
sicherlich auch in gewisser form
abgestuft aber ich verweise jetzt auf
die regierungserklärung unseres kanzlers
die agrana abgegeben hat das bekenntnis
aller nato staaten nato territorium zu
verteidigen steht und auf grund der des
verhaltens von wladimir putin in den
letzten 20 jahren was wir bereits oder
vielleicht einige male falsch beurteilt
haben haben wir eine situation wo so
glaube ich auch im westen der zorn auf
das was russland beziehungsweise
wladimir putin betreibt sehr groß ist
von daher glaube ich nicht wirklich
nicht bin davon überzeugt dass
beispielsweise blick auf litauen die
deutsche battlegroup dort abgezogen
würde ganz im gegenteil der kanzler in
einer sauna vorangehenden reden noch mal
deutlich gemacht dass er die absicht hat
beim nato-gipfel vorzuschlagen dass
diese kräfte die sich in den baltischen
staaten befinden verstärkt werden soll
das war schon mal eine idee im jahr 2016
die damals leider verworfen worden ist
aber diese idee kommt jetzt wieder das
zeigt dass die leute die damals die lage
2016 also nach der annexion der krim
beurteilt haben die lage richtig
beurteilt haben und man hätte manche
dinge voraussehen können und sich davor
darauf einstellen können
letzte frage herr amt von mir sie hatten
für ihn angesprochen dass der krieg wohl
noch einige zeit dauern werde was
glauben sie welche kampftaktik der
ukraine werden wir da in den nächsten
wochen und monaten erleben vor allem
wenn es bei dieser übermacht der russen
bleiben sollte die materiell offenbar
momentan vorhanden ist wird es dazu sei
eine art rea krieg kommen der offenbar
dann sehr blutig werden wird der ist ja
ohnehin schon mutig dieser krieg aber
könnte es dann nochmal eine weitere
dimension geben mit häuserkampf und
allem
also ich möchte noch mal einen punkt
deutlich unterstreichen das was zurzeit
in der ukraine passiert dass der
vormarsch der russischen streitkräfte
jeweils durch eine artilleriefeuer weise
unterstützt wird die ganze ortschaften
zerstört die keine rücksicht auf die
zivilbevölkerung nimmt ist ein
untragbarer und haltbarer zuschaltbar
zustand auch mit blick auf die liste der
kriegsverbrechen von russischer seite
her die immer länger wird
die frage ob man einen party sagen oder
guerilla krieg führen wird hängt zum
teil ab vom gelände das gelände muss
sich für eine solche formen des kampfes
eignen die ukrainischen kräfte müssen in
der lage sein russische streitkräfte
schnell anzugreifen zu schlagen und dann
schnell wieder zu verschwinden bevor sie
beispielsweise von einer neuen
russischen athlon ii feuerwalze erfasst
werden das ist eine möglichkeit die aber
wie gesagt gelände abhängig ist und die
ich im augenblick so noch nicht sehe
obwohl sie mich das richtig im kopf habe
sich von person und einem abschnitt der
südlich des flusses nicht bereits
praktiziert wird der nato general egon
ramms war das für uns mit seinen
einschätzungen zur vor allem
militärischen situation in der ukraine
ganz herzlichen dank herr rams für das
gespräch